the sun rises over the calm Waters of
the Gaza Beach excitement fills the air
as hundreds of children gather near the
shoreline
banners that treat Gaza swimming
Carnival flutter in the gentle breeze
this initiative is a message of peace
and love to the whole world Gaza with
over 25 other countries worldwide will
be going into the sea at the same time
in solidarity with Gaza so the world
knows that Gaza wants Peace and Freedom
away from the destruction and Siege
around a thousand children who have
recently learned to swim take their
first steps into the sea a symbol of
their Newfound confidence
lifeguards stand watchfully by ensuring
the safety of the young swimmers
10 years old says he is participating to
tell the world that the children of Gaza
deserve to live freely like other
children we are under the siege of
Israelis so many children can't do
things like normal citizens would do so
I'm here to send a message to say that
Palestinian children should have their
freedom in the face of Israel's blockade
these children have Gaza embrace the sea
as a symbol of resilience through their
Carriage they redefine boundaries
proving to the world that with
determination they can overcome any
restrictions they face
but this is not just a local event in
over two dozen locations worldwide
people are swimming in harmony with Gaza
standing in solidarity with its people
their shared goal to provide
opportunities for Palestinian children
to learn a skill that can save lives I'm
joining swimwear Gaza to give these
children an opportunity to learn to swim
this will keep them safer and give them
some sense of childhood in the apartheid
they're living in
the funds raised will go towards
providing swimming lessons for
Palestinian children empowering them
with a vital life skill and a sense of
achievement
back in Gaza the children Gather in a
straight line on the beach they hold
hands it raised them high forming a
chain of unity and Hope
in the waters of Gaza and Beyond a
ripple of solidarity has been created
sending the message that compassion
knows no borders you may see it Al
Jazeera Gaza Strip
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera